سلسله اعتقالات شملت عددا من الشخصيات في
تونس لا شيء يربط بينها رغم تزامنها لكنها
اثارت جدلا واسعا في المشهد السياسي بسبب
ما وصفه محامو غالب الموقوفين بخلو
الملفات من اي تهم وقضايا واضحه المدير
العام لاذاعه موزاييك الخاصه احد
المشمولين بالايقاف قالت محاميته ان
الاسئله التي وجهت اليه في اثناء التحقيق
اقتصرت على مصادر تمويل الاذاعه وخطها
التحريري لم يختلف الامر مع رجل الاعمال
كمال لطيف والناشطين السياسيين عبد الحميد
الجلاصي وخيام التركي والازهر العكرمي وقت
للانسان ما عنده شيء على المتهمين سوى حقد
عليهم لانهم معارضين وبالتالي حاول يشوههم
بكل الوسائل وكل التهم وفاق لتغيير هيئه
الدوله بالقوه وين الوفاق هذا اكد سمير
ديلو محامي القيادي بحركه النهضه نور
الدين البحيري انه اعتقل بسبب تصريح
اعلامي تمديد من المعارضه بحمله
الاعتقالات التي نفذتها السلطه ضد عدد من
الشخصيات والرئيس قيس سعيد يتعهد بمحاسبه
من وصفهم بالمتامرين على امن الدوله
يؤكد الرئيس قيس سعيد خلال حديثه مع عدد
من قيادي وزاره الداخليه انما وصفها بمهمه
انقاذ تونس من المتامرين والمجرمين
متواصله وان تهام الموقوفين تتعلق بالتامر
على امن الدوله وتهديد مستقبل شعبها لا
بالحقوق والحريات
هؤلاء الذين تم اعتقالهم ارهابيين
ولابد ايضا ان يحاسبوا بالقانون ولكن لم
نترك تونس لقمه
لهؤلاء المجرمين
الارهابيين الذين يريدون التنكير بالشعب
التونسي وفي حين بدات هذه الاعتقالات فصلا
جديده من فصول الصراع بين الرئيس سعيد
ومعارضيها فانها ايضا تعمق من خلافه مع
اتحاد الشغل اكبر المنظمات النقابيه في
البلاد ميسالفه ناصي الجزيره تونس